I really believe I mean I'm a strange
sort of the paradox because people who
know me know that I'm a very unpleasant
cynical caustic person you know if you
want to know something unpleasant about
somebody as Dorothy Parker used to say
sit by me
[Music]
it talks to you it actually sits down
with you and says you know did you know
I'll bet you didn't know that everyone's
little finger just fits their nostril or
whatever it is whatever it is that it
wishes to convey your mind takes this
incoming acoustical pattern and searches
a dictionary for a matching pattern now
if you have a matching pattern you have
you get the feeling of understanding if
you have no matching pattern you said
what what do you say what but the most
uncool thing that can happen in an
environment where people are trying to
communicate is for one person to say to
another excuse me
would you tell me what it was that I
just said immediately it comes to a
screeching halt because in fact most
communication is going on in the
dimension of uh-huh yeah
no real communication at all the house
knocks the witch down and she's in
Munchkinland and the head of the
Munchkins comes with a scroll and they
all have very squeaky voices and they
sing a little song about so the
munchkins come these hyperdimensional
machine elf entities and they bathe you
in love the manure deposit is a vector
for insect protein in this environment
and having a limited amount of energy
they look for food in the place where
it's likely to be however by a marvelous
coincidence or superb planning on the
part of the extraterrestrials who rule
the galaxy you can sort of choose your
poison
the the lunatic fringe is not
unrepresented good good of which I'm
number myself among them there are some
wild thinkers out there far wilder than
me
of you know if you want to read a wild
book read hunts merav expulsion the
future of human and artificial
intelligence there's a book and I'm
having a memory lapse here help me out
Tipler I said help me out with a memory
lapse you don't have to read my mind for
God's sake
yes thank you who Creon TIFF tipplers
book is a the end of all speculation
where artificial intelligence is
concerned and it's this weird political
correctness where people do not say what
you just said is preposterous it makes
no sense whatsoever this is just thought
so ungenerous of spirit to point out
someone makes no sense at all it's that
their feelings I think have become
preeminent in the value system it's more
important not to hurt someone's feelings
than to let them walk around with a head
full of crap so having identified this
as a problem and having never been
terribly sensitive to other people's
feelings and even to send to the RAM
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you hear somebody lead with
credentials X NASA scientists I just
feel like I should reach for my revolver
how many X NASA scientists are there
with crack-brained ideas and is this why
they're X NASA scientists because they
had to be let go because their belief in
xiii planets higher-dimensional gods on
the face of mars and so forth and so on
interfered with them doing their job I
mean how many how many philandering
zimmy's have to parade before us how
many cog EWP's with a Budweiser welded
to their good right hand do we have to
encounter before you get the message you
know these guys are just slime balls at
worst and lost souls at best and you're
smarter than they are by an order of
magnitude anyway so why waste your time
now if you want to follow if you just
can't tear yourself away from the
concept of following then you know how
about Plato Heraclitus Parmenides
platanus Pro CLIs you know dead guys
they're much safer
you know they're not going to try and
climb into your wallet or some delicate
portion of your Anatomy plus they've
been used tested in the historical arena
and have been found to be generally at
at least harmless at worst and in some
cases actually to be recommended
so I don't consider myself a shaman I'm
more like you know court jester and
village Bard